this woman is being scolded for being
outside without a facemask
it was chased back into her home thank
you thank these people are being
admonished for hanging out in a group
they were all caught by Chinese
authorities who've been deploying drones
equipped with high-resolution cameras
and loudspeakers it's one part of
China's massive surveillance strategy to
tackle the spread of the corona virus
which has reached just about every
region in the country the virus has
infected more than 80 thousand in China
resulting in the deaths of more than
2,000 people in the country far
surpassing the death toll from SARS the
difference between 2003 and 2020 you
know is really enormous in terms of the
government's reliance on and development
of surveillance technology almost none
of these these tools were on offer at
that time Sophie Richardson is the China
director at Human Rights Watch she says
during this public health crisis China
is embarking on an unprecedented use of
surveillance by using big data and its
citizens so what exactly is China's
surveillance strategy and can it work to
battle the epidemic there are an
estimated more than 300 million
surveillance cameras in China and
authorities are using them to monitor
Chinese citizens many of the
surveillance cameras in use in China now
are equipped with facial recognition
capabilities which simply gives the
authorities the ability to track who
specifically has gone to which precise
location combine that with data scraped
from hospital records police files and
public transportation history all that
is stored and linked to national ID
cards which gives the Chinese government
granular information about all its
citizens in January a man who tested
positive for the corona virus used
public buses and Subway's to crisscross
china's eastern city of nanjing the
police posted his journey with specific
dates and times on social media with a
warning that anyone who is in that area
get tested for the virus
China's public health authorities have
been candid about the use of big data
during this public health crisis
Talya caution me me so it's just to do
their clinic see it's chilly what's here
so can see they even developed a mobile
phone app called the close contact
detector the app has a database of
people who have tested positive or have
symptoms so as soon as you type in your
name and national ID and login the app
will tell you if you've ever come into
close contact with someone who tested
positive or if you're in the clear so
far more than 200 million people have
used the app these new in different uses
of technology around the coronavirus may
help resolve some of the public health
concerns but it's also another way for
the government to gather large amounts
of information about people really
effectively without their consent and in
some cases without even their knowledge
Chinese health officials say all this
data is in the pursuit of controlling
the epidemic dhinam couldn't teamed with
a marching decent dharna me a facial
deep jungle booming Yoji should with
geez aluminium in china many people
probably had not developed that kind of
awareness in terms of protecting the
privacy preparedness civil liberties
young John Wong studies global health at
the Council on Foreign Relations in the
US he says many in China want this type
of monitoring because it's about life or
death and when they were given the
choices of protecting their health and
protecting the civil liberties probably
would choose the former even to the
detriment of the latter Huang says
increasing population control during a
health crisis can be a slippery slope
this widespread use surveillance
technologies may also encourage the use
of the same technologies
surveillance techniques even after the
outbreak you know for purposes may not
be really justifiable people are also a
big part of its surveillance apparatus
after all President Xi Jinping said the
fight against the virus was a people's
war authorities send out text messages
telling people to go directly to
authorities if they come from Hebei
province where the corona virus first
emerged and announcements are posted all
around town encouraging everyone to
monitor each other police patrol streets
telling people without face masks to go
home some managers of apartment
complexes go door to door to check on
residents health conditions this may and
sort of suggested this revival of this
comfortable-looking a year away you saw
those people monitoring and their
neighbors they or even their relatives
some provinces have started giving an
incentive to monitor family members
travel histories and health in Sichuan
province in western China snitching can
snag you as much as five thousand yuan
that's roughly equivalent to a monthly
salary that's more than minimum wage one
government in Guangdong province is
offering 30 face masks in exchange for
snitch reports during this public health
crisis China hasn't been the only
country to use technology to track
patients in South Korea health
authorities are legally allowed to sift
through credit card records CCTV footage
and mobile phone locations to pin down
the travel histories of those infected
or at risk that information is then
shared with the public in China
surveillance state not only do
authorities have access to more data
than other governments but citizens have
no way to opt out of that data
collection Beijing says all this is in
the best interest of the public will
have to be able to see how the virus
ultimately played out who is protected
he wasn't whether the surveillance
technology helped
you